bonsoir bonsoir je suis les soupirs bloc
derrière moi il ya quelques téloche qui
sont un peu arrangés n'importe que
m'enfin ça voudrait ressembler une
oeuvre d'art en fait c'est beaucoup plus
simple que ça puisque c'est le mérite au
stop c'est le seul jeu de télé z donc on
va essayer de réussir avec moi pour
m'aider dans cette tâche assez difficile
vous appelez à isabelle il s'appelle je
vous présente alors ça gaze et bah ouais
bien fait une bise
oui c'est spontané
les postes qui sont devant vous
contiennent des clips qui vont démarrer
tout à l'heure et plus c'est petit plus
c'est facile et plus c'est gros plus
c'est plus que plus c'est dur là
d'accord d'accord donc dès que sa part
vous me donnez le titre du clip
l'interprète et l'affairé est dans le
sac il faudrait un arbitres donc je vais
venir l'entv lui les bienvenus vous
appelez bueno bruno vous êtes sérieux
ah oui ça sinon sa valeur je vais vous
mettre quelque chose pas sur la tête
mais autour de la taille par une cellule
vous voulez ça peut faire fuller aussi
aux non jouer le match et vous êtes
l'arbite donc c'est sur vous que repose
tout le jeu un peu oui vous êtes prêts
martial hockey impeccable donc on va
maintenant lancer le disque pour faire
le tirage au sort je vais dans la poule
puisque vous choisissez la version
marque de la version de marquer ont
marqué ou marquent
ok ça roule impeccable c'est donc vous
qui allez commencer alors plus c'est
gros plus c'est dur et plus vous marquez
de points forcément alors c'est quand
vous voulez vous me donner un numéro et
on y va
je vais prendre ma le 8 prenez le 8 mai
sans se dégonfler
topp a nié tout
[Musique]
mais une extase inxs bonnes réponses le
succès inespéré si vous l'avez louis -
white boy black girls like boys non et
bien non pas du tout non pas du tout
finalement pas du tout donc on va vous
poser une petite question pourrait
départager
ouais ok combien y at-il de à dans deux
de bonnes réponses valent maintenant
c'est vous qui avez la main et c'est
vous qui choisissez sur l'ensemble des
postes de téloche qui sont allés voir le
3 le 3 alors attention pour le 3 tops
magnéto d'ailleurs ça ne me suffit pas
me suffit
faire un petit boulot avec la réponse
est chaud et aussi pour automobiles
cheqaoui d'annecy impeccable belle
réponse d'israël
et
ça se bagarre s'était c'était les mythes
les mais limite limite vous garder la
main donc nous vous écoutons faites
votre choix j'essaye de 6,2 et 6,6 alors
attention pour le ciss top magnéto
[Musique]
ok d'accord
pas mal pour un début elle faisait rien
bon on essaye que la wave ou comme moi
pas moi j'ai les filles je suis un peu
pistonné je peux vous dire que c'était
janet jackson escapade à huy après
forcément on fait le malin donc
maintenant une petite question niveau
cm2 pour vous départager
lequel de ces stewart n'est pas chanteur
dave rod james jones james bond
le secteur du dimanche c'est la défaite
des asem donc vous gardez la main je
vais craquer sur le 10 ans grec se
ravisera samedi
attention on joue gros sur le 10 top
magnéto
[Musique]
bien what do better world comme le reste
depuis d'autres ici ça c'était le
attendait si je suis un pistonné mais
j'ai quand même des fiches donc one
better world a ici et on est sec et donc
j'ai une petite question pour vous
départager attention donc deuxième
question non au cm2 ça vaut dix fois ça
vous dit points et ont épaulé les gros
vous êtes attendus moi aussi
quel chanteur grec descendu gorille
demis roussos
attention top magnéto week-end a annoncé
fabriquer leurs auteurs au canal vox à
jouer jour tombés pour la france entière
[Applaudissements]
et là on est tombé pour rien et isabelle
vous avez beau vous jeter la tête la
première contre le petit télé vous
prenez quand même une petite casquette
vous avez gagné
l'émission c'est elle que vous avez
gagné donc vous allez pouvoir choisir
parmi ces dix postes de télé celui que
vous avez envie d'avoir dans votre
cuisine enfin j'espère que vous avez une
grande cuisine dans ce jeu le buzz dans
mes toilettes dans vos toilettes c'est
pas mal j'ai plus grande
d'accord avec vous prenez lequel j'ai
peut-être paraître mégalo je prends le
dise vous prenez le black mamba le
superbe lac le plus bronze est bon le
bronze est bradée ok voilà
allez pas repartir les mains vides donc
vous avez le choix entre le minuscule et
le tout petit point noir pour le moose
qu un minuscule le numéro un oui bon si
ça vous plaît ça j'aurais préféré un
boulot mais forcément non plus donc vous
avez le numéro un il rentrera dans votre
sac à main
oui et vous l'emporterez partout avec
vous en pensez en inde où j'espère je
remercie dieu d'avoir participé bruno si
vous n'avez pas football la semaine
prochaine brawn avec nous ouais je
prends les autres gars de la semaine
prochaine merci c'était magnétoscope
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux